Citizens have the inalienable right to
benefit from the results of their own
illness.
Labor.
That's a good one.
Yes.
That's a conservative truism.
You know why?
Well,
it isn't because you,
because you're goodhearted and you want
them to have money.
It's because they'll work if you let
them benefit from the work and you want
them to work because if they work then
they do things that you need.
It's as simple as that.
It's self interest and it's the right
kind of self interest.
So if you work hard,
it's like great.
Have your money,
you know,
and you hear people all the time talking
about how corrupt our society is and how
the one percent,
you know,
occupies this pinnacle position.
You know,
the one percent turns over pretty damn
fast just so you know it.
So you have about a 10 percent chance of
spending at least one year in the top.
One percent chance during your life.
I think that's right.
I think it's 10 percent.
It might be higher than that,
but it's fast.
It does.
The one percent is stable as a
phenomena,
but it turns over very rapidly in terms
of who occupies it,
and it's the same in every society.
The wealth is always distributed
inequitably.
It's a natural law.
You can look it up.
It was discovered by a guy named Wilfred
Prieto back in the late 18.
Hundreds.
Goods tend to dominate to distribute
themselves inequitably.
It can be a problem,
but it doesn't mean that there's
something fundamentally corrupt about
the social structure that's driving it
in that direction and like you,
you don't want some filthy rich geniuses
lying around like maybe you do.
Let me look at what Elon Musk is doing
for God sake,
maybe he should have 10 times as much
money as he has.
He's going to launch a rocket every five
days to Mars in the next 10 years,
right?
He wants to wipe out fossil fuel cars
and he might do it.
He wants to revolutionize the
transportation system and he might do
it.
He wants to put us on the damn solar
grid with his new batteries and he might
do it.
It's like,
oh no,
he has a couple of billion dollars.
Well God only knows what he's going to
produce with that.
It's like,
so obviously there's going to be some
corrupt.
There's gonna be some corrupt rich
plutocrats who do nothing but smoke
cigars and snort cocaine.
They're not going to live very long
anyways,
but there's lots of people out there who
have the money they have because they
would really like to do interesting and
creative things with it.
Not because they're interested in
gathering more,
you know,
paper money to stuff in their mattress
and to like to feel the smooth,
the smooth delight of gold coins between
their fingers before they go to bed.
Like what kind of attitude is that
towards people who've made their
fortune?
You know,
you think that about Steve Jobs.
You think about Bill Gates.
I mean,
good God,
I don't know how those people make a lot
of money,
but man,
thank God they were around.
You know,
they've given us some tools that are
just absolutely unbelievable.
So you know,
maybe we could leave the jealousy of the
successful behind for a while and notice
now and then that some of the people who
got to where they are actually deserved
to get to where they are and we should
be thankful that they exist.
That would be nice.
A little gratitude and that's a good
conservative value to.
It is more noble to teach young people
about responsibilities down about
rights.
That's a good conservative message.
It's like you have a son or you have a
daughter and you say,
bloody well grow up.
Stand on your own two feet and make
something of yourself right so that I
can be proud of you when you come over.
And so that may be your useful in a
crisis.
It's like pick up your damn load and,
and,
and shoulder it and do something useful.
And,
and forget about your damn rights for
awhile.
You can think about what it is that you
should be doing to benefit yourself and
your family and society and you'll find
some purpose in your life because of
that.
And so,
well,
that's a counter position to the
perpetrators of the endless rights
buffet,
right?
Well,
as long as we give you enough rights,
you're going to be what?
Free.
You're going to be happy.
It's like,
yeah,
sure you'll drown in a sea of chaos.
And that's what's happening to people
now too.
So.
And that's why young people are so
hungry to have someone talk to them
about responsibilities.
Here's another one.
Radical change should be viewed with
suspicion,
particularly in a time of radical
change.
Okay?
There's never been a time in the history
of the world where things are changing
as fast as they are now.
And not only are they changing fast,
the rate at which they're changing is
increasing.
Like we're moving fast forward at such a
rate that it's unbelievable.
You can't even keep up.
I don't care what discipline you're in.
It's like it's not so bad to have some
people putting their feet in the ground.
They're digging their heels in and say,
look,
we got a lot to swallow already.
We've got a lot to chew on and Digest.
Let's not muck about with everything
that's worked so far,
what has worked,
not such a bad idea for people to have
long term families,
right?
We could say,
let's try to support the family.
We could even say,
let's try to support the traditional
family.
Why?
Well,
maybe boys and girls need role models of
each sex.
I know that's a terrible thing to say,
but it is possible.
It's certainly the case too that intact
two parent families have children that
thrive more than broken families and
broken families or a catastrophe for
everyone.
Now you might say,
well,
I shouldn't stay with someone that I
don't get along with,
and it's like,
yeah,
fair enough.
Except that there is no one that you're
ever going to find to stay with it.
You're going to get along with all of
the time,
especially in your shoddy condition,
and so you're lucky that anybody.
Oh,
you're lucky that anybody will put up
with him for a week much less your whole
life.
It's like the point of marriage is to
tough it out and you don't tough it out
for your happiness.
That's not what you're in there for,
your tough it out so that you have
someone to tie the rope of your life
together with.
You have a chance to tie the rope of
your life together with the rope of
someone else's life and to make it
strong and to make a place that children
can have some security and some
encouragement and thereby contribute to
the future and pay for the miracle of
your birth and your own raising.
That's why you get married and there's
no reason that conservatives can stand
up and say,
look,
we're willing to tolerate alternative
family arrangements,
but when you start making the claim that
the traditional family unit is just
another construct and that it's not
something fundamental to our polity,
it's like that's.
You've taken your damn argument too far.
First of all,
you have no evidence whatsoever for that
claim and there's plenty of counter
evidence.
So,
you know,
one of the things the postmodernists
basically say is,
you know,
every time you stand up for something,
you're also standing against something.
It's like,
yeah,
that's true,
but that doesn't mean that you shouldn't
stand up for things.
And I think if,
if there is something that conservatives
could agree on that we could stand up
for,
it's the nuclear family now.
Exactly how that's gonna play out.
I don't exactly know,
but it's nothing to.
It's not anything to be ashamed of to
say,
wow,
it kind of looks like that structures
work quite well for the entire duration
of mankind.
And so maybe we mess with it at our
apparel.
Here's another one.
The government,
local and distant should leave people to
their own devices as much as possible.
Why?
Well,
part of it's just humility.
It's like I'd rather that there was a
million of you out there making your own
stupid mistakes so that maybe a thousand
of you can get it right then for one of
you to impose their view on everyone and
risk getting it catastrophic,
wrong for everyone at the same time.
And that's really the alternative.
Like if you're a social scientist,
like I mean an actual scientist,
I don't mean a bloody idiot log.
One of the things that you learned very
rapidly,
as you know,
you do a simple experiment.
You think you're going to predict some
element of human behavior,
so here's my hypothesis.
I'm going to put people in this
experimental situation and this is what
they're going to do,
and then you run the experiment and they
don't do that.
They do something completely different.
You find out that even though what you
have them do is really simple,
you don't have a clue what they're up to
and that's just a tiny little controlled
experiment about one little tiny thing
and you're wrong.
It's like
one of the great advantages to
conservative philosophy is that it's
humble.
It's humble from,
uh,
from the perspective of social
experimentation.
It's like,
it's not like everything's great and we
should just continue going the way we're
going.
It's like,
well,
everything isn't as broken as it might
be and I'm kind of stupid and blind and
all I have is a bat and probably hitting
it isn't going to make it any better.
Oh,
I'll do is shatter it.
And so the conservative says it's
working
quiet,
sneak away.
Maybe it'll keep working.
And that's a perfectly reasonable
perspective.
Now obviously sometimes things have to
change,
but the conservative can come up and
say,
don't be thinking that you have so much
evidence that what you're doing is right
or that it will have the outcome that
you expected.
I'll tell you a quick story,
and this was told to me by a woman named
Joan mccord who was one of the world's
first female criminologist,
by the way,
a phd from temple,
University of a genius level,
genius level person.
Very tremendous integrity,
tough,
tough person.
She did a study in a place called
Somerville in the United States in
Massachusetts in the 19 thirties famous
study,
and so here is the deal.
They'd identified a bunch of inner city
kids in rough neighborhoods and felt
that they were more likely to be on a
criminal track,
criminal antisocial,
undereducated,
alcoholic,
the whole,
the whole dismal,
wretched,
underclass phenomena thing was going on.
And so they thought,
well,
let's do an intervention.
Let's set up programs to help these kids
and see if we can see if we can change
their developmental pathway.
So
they designed to find study.
Man,
I had the kids.
I'll get the details wrong,
but I got the.
I got the story right.
They had the kids,
they made them more literate.
They educated the more they had their
parents take training courses.
They did social skills training like
they did all sorts of things to try to
make the kids' lives turn out better and
to top it all off because the kids were
stuck in the inner city.
I took them all out to summer camp for a
couple of weeks,
a year and so they could get away from
the city and you know,
enjoy the countryside and have a little
bit of a vacation,
a little taste of a higher quality life.
Yeah.
So great.
Everyone's thrilled with the damn
program.
The kids are having a great time at
camp.
The counselors do thrilled the
psychologists.
They think they're doing a wonderful
job.
Great.
It's working beautifully.
Except then they did the data analysis.
Guess what happened?
The kids in the.
In the treatment group,
there was a control group,
right?
That didn't get all this special
treatment randomly assigned.
It was a very nice experiment.
The kids in the treatment group did
worse on virtually everything that was
measured worse.
Why
don't put out any social kids together
in the same camp for two weeks during
the year.
Right?
Right.
Because what happens is that the bad
kids teach the slightly less bad kids to
be worse.
It's a well documented phenomenon.
That's why what happens in prisons
happens in prisons.
What we do with criminals is the worst
thing you could possibly do to criminals
if you don't want them to continue to be
criminals,
except for the fact that you keep them
in there until they're old enough,
generally speaking,
so they're less likely to engage in
criminal activity,
but what was learned from the Somerville
study was don't be so sure your good
intentions are going to produce the
results that you intend because they
probably won't and they probably won't
for reasons that you never even
imagined,
and the other one was
don't group bad kids with good kids on
the assumption that the good kids will
make the bad kids better because that
isn't what happens.
What happens is the reverse.
If you put two or three bad kids with a
bunch of good kids,
then the good kids get worse.
The bad kids don't get better.
Very well documented social science
finding,
well the reason I'm telling you the
Somerville story is because God who
could argue with that study,
right?
It's like these kids were poor.
They were struggling.
It's like you want to.
You want to lift them up,
you want to make their life better.
You do this wonderful expensive,
well motivated experiment and then you
run the damn data analysis and you find
out that there was one thing wrong with
your social intervention philosophy that
didn't understand and you actually made
it worse.
Well,
that's a and so Joel,
Joel Mccord,
she spent much of the rest of her life
going around telling social scientists.
When you run a social experiment,
politicians,
the same thing when you run a social
experiment,
especially on a large number of people,
especially without their consent,
then gather the data and do the followup
study because it's highly probable that
you'll find that what you did didn't
work or maybe it even worked backwards
and you'll never know that unless you do
this study,
and so what people took away from that,
the social intervention is types took
away from that was whatever you do with
your social intervention policy,
don't run the study.
Right,
right.
That was the wrong lesson,
by the way.